vous savez jamais les michael et al gore
il ya la france qui joue ce soir hier
alors qu'il joue ce soir contre les
horreurs qu on y va allez les gars est
ce que voulait pas qu'on allait faire un
petit tour parce qu'on nous l'avait
demandé hier sur twitter à 15 juil oui
tout à fait parce qu'on sent on s'ennuie
un peu on va pas me faire un petit tour
sur i télé je conduis à ce cas pascal
praud a ils sont directs à ce qu'on
pourra tous si elle est devenue un des
seuls
abrité la différence a dit isabelle sera
sympa et claviers vas-y toi pascal et
travailler avec des as
allez monsieur sapin à l'aller ce
monsieur allez je vous inquiétez pas
allez-y mais si ça passe a pas baladé
par 10 de m
l'équipe de france contre un cypher et
voilà les bleus allez allez
allez
m
chez moi
chez vous rien vous cacher je
comprendrais jamais voir si gentil mari
limitation côté patrick mallet
soyez sympa oui dites nous ce que vous
pensez du match ce soir
nous sommes dans une émission sérieux
pour s'éviter nouveau oui on va y aller
pour gagner on va aller dans 3 0 ap à la
pub sur laon sera promet du groupe après
huitièmes de finale
non j'ai rien mais je n'ai geria et j'en
ai ensuite quart de finale contre
l'allemagne allemagne on passe demi
finale contre le brésil est terminée et
voilà c'est l'impression que ça
s'enflamme un petit peu commun face à
rooney
jeudi le jt a son mot à dire ouais
l'algérie en demi-finale cette coupe du
monde est déjà gagnée pour la frangine à
l'algérie j'ai trouvé l'amour de notre
équipe et cette équipe a retrouvé
l'amour du ballon
si jamais la vérité serait ce qu'un oeil
les supporters